you are so good in this show how much
fun are you having with this role
I had immense one from the incredible
music it's a great wardrobes the immense
settings and um to boot one of the most
gorgeous lovely casts
I can only imagine was that really you
singing in that first episode we saw yes
that like
it was it was incredible it was a great
Challenge and I was very nervous
um about it all to start with but we
work with the most incredible team
um adamandas they're so talented and I
think the more confidence grew the
better the the easier it became but um
yeah and we had we had a lot of help we
had lots of Reverb and a great studio
and like some of the when we came to
recording the song we'd be in the studio
and I might sing one line about 10 or 12
times so I get it because the note that
kept coming through is that sounds a
little Irish
background the light is Wine Not wine
more difficult not just having to
pretend you're one of the greatest
country singers but um to have to sing
in accent so it means the placement's
completely different I had to choose
that's a whole other level you're right
because your accent in this show is so
phenomenal was that challenging all on
its own you know aside from the singing
um it was more of a joy than the
challenge I'm gonna stick a little bit
of a perfectionist and I I work with so
many accents over a 30-year career in
this particular accent um is a joy to
perform and so lyrical and melodic
um and I had a superb voice coach and
for the first it was good the shoot
ended up being extended because of many
covered lockdowns
um but I stayed in accident for the
first four months on set without no one
heard this accent I told my dad the
whole time just just so that it would
become it will become naturalistic
dialogue changed um and you get used to
using different muscles but I I love
changing accents it's really fun I've
been doing this as a kid
well you nailed it then because that
makes sense you put so much work into it
like it's it's so good this show is
great that first season ends on such a
wild Cliffhanger there's actually
several Cliffhangers is this what the
audience is in for after every episode
like how much drama are we gonna get
well I think
um it would it lends itself very well
for water cooler chat you're gonna be if
you have to wait for the next week is
what what's gonna happen where's it
gonna go
um yeah it's full of twists and turns I
don't think you'll be able to predict
what happens there's things that I even
when we got to episode six we'd see an
episode seven thinking not having any
clue which direction it was going to go
in
it hooks you well I definitely felt that
way after the first episode Susan
Sarandon as Dottie is maybe the most
perfect casting ever the queen of
country music why is she so good in this
role
aside from the fact that she's an
amazing actress because because she's a
a fantastic actress who can lend herself
to any part at any time
um she's she's beautiful she's talented
she's smart and I think she herself owns
this immense strength that is needed to
play Yoshi
um I think she's perfect casting it's
been a lifelong dream of mine to get to
be able to work with her so I felt
honored to share the screen oh I love
that so she what you thought when you're
on set and in between scenes what was it
like the chemistry you two had on set so
down to earth warm intelligent again
just she's she's such a sexy lady she
just loses she is she really really is
and just owns herself
um yeah more impressive than I could
ever
dreamed of and the story she has amazing
stories please tell me another one
um yeah
that's fun uh okay so if she is if Susan
Sarandon is playing the queen of country
music who is your queen of country music
who do you love
without sounding obvious uh and I think
there's been many people's uh answer I'm
a huge Dolly fan I just I love the only
part of life I just I love the fun and
the energy and the warmth and the sheer
commitment the hard I don't think people
and I didn't certainly understand or
realize just how much work goes into
being a country music star who's touring
that Trace was in between Israel he was
still on tour and they would be on the
on his tour bus all night go and perform
and then come back to the set
um it's it's a lot of work and I admire
her very much for that and she also
makes you dance and you can't help but
sing along it's true she always seems
like she's in the best mood ever and
she's just loving every moment of this
it's incredible all the time the amount
of effort
effort to that and it still just seems
warm and Char and charming and not jaded
um after such a long and healthy
successful career yeah was there anybody
in the country music scene that you
looked up to or that you really paid
attention to when you were crafting your
character
I thought it was important
um not to create a caricature or base it
on any one particular person I watch
documentaries and read books and and
listen all the time but the script very
much dictated who Nikki Roman was and it
was a journey of Discovery over a nine
month period
um she takes lots of different shifts
and turns and you know I kind of grew
into my character it was more for me it
was more about having and learning the
confidence that you deserve to be on the
stage
because I think as actors we're we're
always told not we were not always told
we don't look into the camera when they
look at it we ignore it as if it's not
there and the very different challenges
as an artist as you're on a stage and
you're you're you're willingly audience
you're bringing them all together to own
that space takes great confidence
what was your first reaction when you
read the script
the first reaction when I read the
student I thought I've not seen anything
like this for a long time this is yeah
very very interesting
um and I thought it was sort of really
entertaining uh unique characters and I
was really fascinated to see how you
could blend drama with
um with with with with the musical
elements of it
well congratulations on the series
cannot wait to watch the rest thank you
so much I hope you enjoy I love I love
Canada I've filmed that many times it's
a wonderful country yay I loved you in
pushing Daisy so just saying I'm a huge
fan thank you thanks